David Garrow is a historian has written
extensively on the FBI in a number of
different books in a piece for today's
Wall Street Journal he says that some
members of Congress including some
Democrats may be reverting to the jig or
Hoover era in their treatment of the FBI
David Garrow joins us tonight David
thanks for coming on we we search great
the way when you Tucker for the last
three days for the last honest liberal
who will stay consistent to the liberal
values of openness and commitment to
civil liberties give us some perspective
here when you hear people say the FBI
would never do that you're attacking
you're attacking our Guardians by asking
that question is there some historical
precedent for this would you say I'm
very worried Tucker at how people are
giving up their principles their civil
liberty principles because of the
intensity of their partisan hatred for
President Trump as you know I'm a
liberal Democrat yeah but what we've got
here is Democrats forgetting the history
of the FBI and taking up these anti
civil liberty stances defending the FBI
simply because of how intensely opposed
they are to President Trump the FBI does
not have a good pedigree on electronic
surveillance practices and everything
I'm aware of as a liberal Democrat is
that the Bureau has been really
deceptive with the foreign intelligence
court in applying for this extended
electronic surveillance of Carter page
the volunteer Trump advisor yes liberals
and progressives should oppose the FBI's
behavior targeting mr. page just on
civil liberties grounds having nothing
to do with the larger investigation or
their like or dislike for Trump but an
American citizen is having a civil
liberties violated liberals should care
right and based primarily or extensively
it appears on the dodgy Christopher
Steele dossier yeah I think we both know
again I'm a liberal Democrat the steel
dossier is CR ap it's BS mr. wordy I
relied upon that in going to Fed
judges to surveil an American citizen
that's offensive to me as a progressive
Democrat exactly David Garrow author of
the definitive biography of the last
President Barack Obama thanks for
joining us tonight Thank You Tucker